25 ans cela fait 25 ans que Montlouis
célèbre le jazz à chaque rentrée c'est
la même chanson quelques notes de piano
entraînante le saxo qui résonne et les
afficionados qui se bousculent au
portillon il y a ceux qui ne sont pas
nés de la dernière pluie ça fait déjà 17
ans je l'ai presque inventé le festival
j'ai vu Jerry mullingham j'ai vu le jazz
Messenger j'ai vu le petit
petoutian et puis puis maintenant moins
connu là vendredi prochain je vais aller
voir
Grove un trompettiste il y a aussi ceux
qui ont été attirés par un nom ça doit
faire il y a de ou 3 ans je suis venue
voir le même concert Goran Bregovic en
fait c'est vrai que j'ai pas eu
l'occasion encore de venir pour voir
autre chose que lui donc parce que voilà
je suis fan tout simplement j'adore et
il y en a d'autres qui viennent
simplement manger au Marché Gourmand je
viens écouter du jazz en mangeant et bah
je viens avoir des copains et c'est
ceuxl même qui développent sans trop
s'en rendre compte leur goût pour le
jazz bah la musique c'est
rigolo bref petits et grands y trouvent
leur compte grâce à un savant mélange de
concerts éclectique entre jazz manouche
cubain et afro-américain tête d'affiche
et révélation le tout dans l'ambiance
conviviale du Marché Gourmand c'est bien
ça la recette de longévité du festival
qui est passé depuis
1987 de 3000 à 25000 spectateurs